what about sex it's important sex
playing a successful relationship well
it okay so I'm saying it's important but
I want to qualify that everybody has
different levels of sex that are
satisfying to them sex can definitely
Bond you to your partner orgasms are
amazing they de-stress us they're
healthy they
I mean you can have an orgasm and have a
lower level of stress for 48 hours I
think that's pretty incredible
um
if you have I mean just that kind of
physical contact with your partner even
a 20-second hug with your partner has
similar benefits to an orgasm you're
going to have a lower stress level
you're going to feel immediately close
to your partner you're going to get a
rush of oxytocin which is going to make
you feel happier more grounded
throughout the day so that's a 20 second
hug you extrapolate that to sex and
things are going to be great
so just physiological but I wonder
there's probably metrics about how often
you have sex how that correlates to
successful relationships and so on well
there are but it really has more to do
it's sort of like remember I was talking
about processing conflict and what
matters is
do people feel like it's been resolved
do they feel like there's been a repair
not necessarily how they go about doing
it same with sex do does each partner
feel sexually satisfied
um so that could be once a month for one
couple it could be five times a week for
another couple it could be never for
other couples truly
um I mean so sex has a ton of benefits
but its absence isn't necessarily
detrimental I guess would be the
qualifier depending on who you are and I
know couples they use sex to as part of
the conflict resolution process it's you
not just both all that's true